pues la verdad es que el segundo día de
votación anticipada aquí en florida ha
transcurrido con total normalidad se han
vuelto a ver estas imágenes de gente
haciendo fila en los exteriores de los
centros de votación querían evitar
esperar hasta el último día o incluso el
día de la elección el día 13 de
noviembre para evitar precisamente el
contacto con muchísima gente a las
personas que están ejerciendo su derecho
al voto dicen que quieren expresar su
voz en las urnas porque quieren que su
voz se escuche porque son unas
elecciones trascendentales también lo
saben tanto el candidato republicano
como el demócrata porque de florida es
el estado clave y aquí quien gane en las
elecciones en este estado va a acabar
siendo el presidente de eeuu por eso se
están fijando mucho en los indecisos
concretamente en la población hispana
porque los cubanos venezolanos o incluso
colombianos podrían acabar decidiendo
quién
para el sillón de presidente en los
próximos cuatro años en la casa blanca
muy bien antonia y welsch y muchas
gracias por tus reportes